Hi, it's Halloween. We're the Ri.
So we're exploding pumpkins.
This year for our explosions we are going
to be using this compound - calcium carbide.
It reacts with water, fizzing away producing
lots of gas
and that gas is acetylene, which you may know
is very flammable.
We send the gas along the tube, filling our
pumpkin with acetylene.
When it's ready, we can light the fuse, ignite
the acetylene,
blowing the face out of our pumpkin.
Calcium carbide is made of calcium ions and
carbide ions.
Carbide ions are two carbons bonded together.
And it's these carbon atoms that are joining
with our hydrogen atoms from the water
to give us a hydrocarbon, in this case acetylene.
Like other hydrocarbons, like petrol,
it's a really great fuel, burns really well
and will give us an awesome explosion to power
our pumpkins.
We've been blowing pumpkins up all day, but
not all of them have blown up.
In fact some of our pumpkins only showed a
small amount of combustion.
And our theory is that these particular pumpkins
had so much acetylene inside of them
that there really wasn't much oxygen for them
to burn with.
Of course we need oxygen to get a good explosion
and without it we're going to get incomplete
combustion.
Another sign of this is the black soot and
smoke
we can see coming out of this particular pumpkin.
We've been collecting and burning loads of
acetylene at once to get an explosion,
but in the early 1900s, miners used a more
controlled version of this reaction
to power their headlamps - carbide lamps.
They would have a rock of calcium carbide
in them
and a small valve to drip water onto it
slowly and steadily, producing a constant
stream of acetylene
that they could light to see their way around
the mine.
Thanks for watching. If you've got any ideas
how we
should explode pumpkins next year, let us
know in the comments.
Don't forget to like and subscribe to the
channel, and happy halloween!